good morning this is Steve here again
Steve Kaufman my blog is the linguist
blogs com of course I'm involved with
the language learning system called link
li and GQ com it's the morning here I
shaved yet i'm going to play hockey
later on with a group of old-timers so
I'm going to shave after my shower but
this morning had a very interesting
email from one of our Brazilian members
at link and of course in my previous
webcast I expressed my allergy to
grammar AZ this particular person put it
and I definitely do believe that grammar
teaching is largely counterproductive
and it has to do with the fact that we
learn from our experience and not
through some logical explanations that
are imposed on us but this person is a
teacher herself and she says well like
is there no role for teachers are you
getting rid of teachers so what is the
role of the teacher in different
situations first of all insofar as
language is concerned I'm quite
convinced that in most situations if we
simply let language learners listen to
things of interest read the same content
and then save words and phrases work on
vocabulary but experience the language
in following their own interests they
will learn at any age much better than
in any formal in class of instruction
now the role of teachers if I think back
to my years at school and university I
can only remember a few teachers and the
only teachers that I remember are the
ones that inspired me I remember nothing
that was taught to me but I remember
teachers that inspired me in high school
there was a teacher for example who got
a group of us to do a recording of Homer
The Odyssey and we recorded different
parts and he was so enthusiastic about
Greek mythology that he got us
enthusiastic quite a lot of us I'm not
just talking about two or three a lot of
us in the class got quite enthusiastic
about Greek mythology
on the other hand we had a French
teacher who was a reverend he wore black
robes we used to call him Zorro whenever
he walked into class we would sing the
theme from Zorro that was a popular TV
program but he was so cynical we
couldn't help picking on him all the
time so he did not inspire enthusiasm we
had a very enthusiastic Latin teacher
who would walk in the room and in those
days we have to stand up when the
teacher walked in the class and he would
draw up his books onto his desk and we
had to sit down before the books hit the
desk simple thing it kind of woke us up
and he was a nice guy and he was
enthusiastic and energetic my interest
in languages began when I went to
university and we had a teacher that
first year miserable time I still
remember him he's the one who got me on
the language learning because he made
french civilization so interesting it's
not what he taught us we got it out of
the books we got it out of I started
reading the local French newspaper i
lived in Montreal I didn't speak French
she even though I had French at school I
wasn't interested because we had a
series of we had one teacher in high
school who came in and he was actually
from England and he said all right you
guys now we're going to talk frog
language well I can tell you that did
not inspire us and so after all these
boring French teachers here was a person
who made french interesting and as a
result I went off on my own and started
learning French and from there I learned
Chinese and I learned a bunch of other
languages but he inspired me so my quick
answer is a teacher has to be able to
inspire the student number one role how
well the teacher has to be enthusiastic
and passionate about about something him
or herself and the teacher has to treat
the student as an individual not as some
kind of an unfortunate social welfare
case unfortunately if you'll be there is
far too much sort of social studies
involved in teaching you know the power
relationships gender relationships
unfortunate student because suffering
from whatever class racial ethnic gender
scrimmage forget all that stuff just
assume that the student has tremendous
potential and is an individual and needs
to be encouraged stimulated praised not
criticize necessarily but also we need
to tell students this this is reality in
life if you want a job you have to do
this how you achieve it is up to you
here are some resources I'm here to help
you but you have to do it on your own I
cannot teach you you can learn and here
are the things that I find fascinating
you may find them fascinating you may
not and maybe my personality will
inspire certain students at certain
students and maybe somebody else's
personality will inspire other students
but I think the role of the teacher is
to inspire to guide to provide feedback
to encourage to support etc not
necessarily to teach and that is
especially the case today when there are
so many resources available in various
media formats through the internet at
the library and so forth and I think
teachers should help your students
access this wider source of information
not hold themselves up as sources of
some great truth and that's especially
the case in grammar I mean people learn
through experience grammar is not some
great magnificent mathematical logical
structure it's full of inconsistencies
it varies from language to language
there's nothing wonderfully mathematical
about it at all it's just usage that's
evolved and has and will continue to
evolve and yes the students have to
identify that the pattern of users that
they want to imitate and they have to
imitate it in learning a foreign
language but it needn't be delivered
through the form of some great
scientific knowledge that the teacher
has that is going to be slowly drip by
drip and drop by drop delivered to the
student ok thank you there again so
that's my bit on the role of the teacher
I hope that satisfies are my letter
writer from Brazil
thank you bye-bye